[Music]
today's question comes from brian in
missouri he asks i'm 27 years old and i
have been working in the natural gas
industry since i was 20. i don't have a
degree and i make very good money and
enjoy the work the last few years it has
seemed that our country is moving away
from my industry i have a fear that late
in my career i could be out of a job is
this a rational fear or am i paranoid
should i be looking into other careers
okay brian uh first of all i think it's
a good question right it's a
forward-thinking question what's going
on in the natural gas industry are these
real trends that we need to be worried
about
or is it just kind of the ups and downs
as we see new types of energy
become available for consumers two
things on this i'm not a natural gas
expert but i have a hard time believing
that the natural gas industry is going
to completely go away i just don't see
that going away
it is still cost effective and i think
it's very viable however you are in the
industry and you need to talk to real
industry
experts in your company
do your homework and figure out is this
something that over time
is going to go completely away that
would be the first question um
so i i don't think that you need to be
fearful i think that you need to be
vigilant there's a difference
i'm looking i'm watching i'm scanning
the future kind of seeing what's moving
but i'm not going to be fearful now the
second thing george
that i would say to brian is
you do a certain type of work in the
natural gas industry
right so you aren't someone who is only
capable of working in that industry
you are in let's call it the energy
industry so therefore whatever you do in
your day-to-day work and the skill set
that you've developed plus the
experience that you've developed is all
going to allow you to move into multiple
different industries so from that
standpoint i wouldn't be afraid at all
yeah i think these skills are going to
transfer to whatever industry if it even
does go away ken like you're talking
about i don't know that it will in our
lifetime i i honestly can't see it
unless natural gas just becomes a
almost like an extinct resource but i
got to tell you um
i use it all the time i've got a world
class griddle george it's huge
um and it connects right to the old uh
gasoline natural gas people love it and
i love to cook on it
all over the country fantastic so yeah i
don't see it going away anytime soon but
i think he does have have a right to
stay afoot he's a smart guy i i would
get the facts unless i start seeing
other natural gas companies shut down
layoffs are happening all around me i
see the writing on the wall but let's
not lose sleep over that right now no
that could be 30 40 100 years from now
here's the key and i want other people
to hear this because this is a relevant
question for a large portion of our
audience
your skill set and your experience
is transferable
i'm going to say it again your skill set
and your experience is transferable
you might need to get a certification
here or there
but the bottom line is
you are not stuck in one industry and i
get this call all the time on the ken
coleman show ken i'm a teacher i want to
get out ken i'm a nurse i want to get
out or whatever it is
we hear this the most from our military
men and women they feel like because
they've only had a career in the
military that they they can't get a job
in the private sector and i said wait a
second you you work for one of the great
organizations in the world and you have
skills yes or no and you have experience
and then where is that transferable in
the private sector the reality is in
today's world our military men and women
are just premium because of their
discipline because of their character
and commitment so
don't get too scared just start looking
into it good encouragement for brian
there thanks for the question